DAN SANDLER: All right,
let's get started.
Thank you everybody for showing
up at 9:00 on Thursday morning.
I very much appreciate it,
it's great to see you here.
Weather is a little
better, so hopefully today
is more fun for everyone.
I guess we've already jumped
ahead to our extended version
of the title of this
talk-- we just stuck with,
"What's New in Notifications
in Android N"-- ooh, OK.
I see what it is,
I'm just resting
my thumb on the advancer,
and so that's the problem.
We definitely rehearsed this--
I swear, I promise to everybody.
But back here for a
little bit and just
say that we're going to talk
about notifications today,
but we're going to spend
about half our time talking
about Android Wear 2.0, because
that got a great big reveal
yesterday at the keynote, and--
[LAUGHTER]
I thought the comedy session
was this evening, not right now.
All right, well,
we'll deal with it.
My name is Dan Sandler,
I'm the lead engineer
on the Android
System UI team, which
is all the stuff you can
see on the screen that's
not any other app.
ALEX HILLS: And I'm Alex Hills.
I'm an engineer on the
Wear System UI team, which
has the exact same description.
DAN SANDLER: But smaller,
and attached to your body.
ALEX HILLS: Still
advancing some, too.
DAN SANDLER: Still
advancing-- oh, man.
This thing, it's on its own.
All right, we're just
going to keep moving.
So we've made some changes
in Android notifications
this year.
We make some changes every year.
This is kind of a
big change this year,
because we've messed
with the templates.
I mean, you see
here we've actually
messed with the templates.
Many times in the
past, this is probably
our first big-- I'm just
going to set this down.
I'm just going to
set that thing down.
We'll advance, maybe, by
hitting the air buttons.
And we've changed it again.
But the reason we've
changed is to bring things
more in line with
material design,
and to make things a
little more scannable.
Generally, we've got room
for a little more text.
You have the ability
to-- I actually do need
to do the builds now.
[LAUGHS] All right,
OK, fantastic.
OK, so we've cleaned things up.
They're a little less busy.
We've hit our material key lines
now, instead of winging it,
like we did before.
You now see that we
can tell you exactly
which app posted each
notification-- that's
accountability for you, the
end user, which we never really
had before, unless you knew to
long press in the notification.
So that's good.
And we've taken the
icons out of actions,
mostly so that you've got more
room for those long labels that
might show up in
some translations.
And then finally, my
personal pet peeve
about notifications,
since we introduced
expandable notifications
in Jelly Bean
is that you can now
tell what's expandable.
There's an expansion
widget-- the little chevron
that appears next to the
app name that lets you see,
oh, there's more text here.
And if I touch that, you
can actually click it,
and it expands the notification.
This slide here--
is there anything
that we can do to
avoid racing through?
I mean, I race through stuff
anyway, but this is ridiculous.
All right, we're going
to hold it right there.
Let's see what happens.
I moved the mouse around.
I'll turn around three times
and spit, if that doesn't work.
This is a slide that
you're not supposed
to be able to follow-- it's
like a London tube map, which
I certainly can't follow.
I just want to motivate that
all of the old information
is still here in the temple,
it's just moved down around
to a new place.
So if you're already using
the Notification Builder APIs,
we'll take care of
all that for you.
We'll move it into new spots.
Another thing that's useful
to note, particularly
as an end user, is where you
can actually touch on things.
So here are the hit targets.
I just want to make a note
that even though that expand
indicator is really
small, the hit target
for it is really big.
You touch anywhere
on that top row,
you expand the
whole notification.
So if you, as a developer,
have been using expanded
notifications, and you're
worried that no user knows
how to find it, this is how.
There's a button you can touch,
finally, after three years.
ALEX HILLS: A button that you
can touch that advances a slide
without meaning to?
DAN SANDLER: Seriously, I don't
know what-- this thing really
likes me to do.
So what do you have to do?
If you're using the
Builder, like I said,
you don't have to do anything.
Everything is already
going to be moved
to the new templates for you.
If you're doing
custom RemoteViews,
you have a lot of
work to do, as you
have every single other
release, because RemoteViews,
you have to re-sculpt
everything from scratch
to make sure that it matches
the new template design.
But help is finally on the
way-- for the very first time,
we have a new template that
is just designed to say,
hey, I've got some
custom content
to put in the
middle of this view,
but please, system, decorate
the rest of it exactly
the way it's
supposed to be done.
So we call it Decorated
Custom View style.
And what you can see
here is essentially
a schematic of the
orange section-- you just
do whatever you want,
inside our RemoteViews,
just like you did before
with custom RemoteViews.
But the system will then put in
the expanded indicator, the app
accountability, the
app name at the top,
and even put in the actions
for you at the bottom.
So if you've got a custom
weather widget, or something
like that, that you want to
have it match the system style,
you're good to go.
Another big new thing
that is new in N--
we didn't talk about it much
at the keynote yesterday,
but if you've been playing along
at home with the N developer
preview, you've seen this--
is that we are now finally,
finally, finally supporting
groups on the phone.
You want me to use this one?
All right, thanks a lot, man.
We have an amazing
crew here today.
Thank you very much.
We actually added notification
groups all the way back
in API 24 Android Wear.
And of course, you've got
this awesome screenshot
from centuries ago
showing the original Wear
1.0 view of how
notification groups look,
as a stack of cards.
And on the phone, yeah, you
just see a summary-- you just
see one thing, usually
you do inbox style
to mask over what
would have otherwise
been a group of really
nice notifications.
Now you can do this
on the phone, as well.
And on tablets, the exact
same APIs move forward.
So if previously,
your app was doing
some sort of looking
around to see
if the Wear companion
was installed--
don't do that anymore.
Just post all of
your notifications
in that group, which you
associate by group key,
and they'll show up this way.
Each one of those notifications
is its own full notification,
so it can be expanded, it
can have its own actions,
and everything.
It's really, really outstanding.
If you haven't used this API
before, it's really easy to do.
You say Set Group when you're
building a notification
with Builder.
The string that
you pass basically
becomes a co-location key
that we use to collect groups
together by name.
You still want to use a summary
notification, for two reasons.
One, this is what will
show on phones pre-N,
because we don't know
how to do groups pre-N,
so we just show the summary.
But in N, we'll
take that summary
and we'll extract little
bits and pieces of it
to make-- do you see that little
header row, right at the top,
above the bundle?
We actually pulled that
information from the summary.
So if, for example,
you are displaying
the group that
represents one inbox,
or one account in
your chat app, that
might be the place that--
because of the summary--
we know, OK, that's
the account name,
and that's what we'll
put in that summary row.
But then each
individual conversation,
or each individual
email thread, then
goes into its own
notification in the group.
And finally, if you want to make
sure that those things appear
in the correct order,
use Set Sort key,
will just sort them,
again, on that string,
lexicographically to make
sure the notifications
show up exactly the way
you want them to see.
The other big end-user feature--
oh, now it's not going.
All right, here we go.
The other big end-user
feature for notifications in N
that you developers need to
know about is direct reply.
And we had this
on Wear, as well,
where you could, essentially,
post a notification
that somebody could
then talk to the watch,
and then that text
would immediately
be sent back to the app, and
you can send and SMS with it.
Now we have it on the phone.
And in fact, you just type
directly into the notification
shade, itself.
It's really awesome,
particularly
from the lock screen.
So I've got a nice
little build here,
you can see you've got a new
message, you touch Reply,
and you're just
typing right in there,
even if it's on the lock screen.
It's fantastic.
If you've never used this API
before-- because again, it
was introduced with
API [? 24 Wear-- ?]
if you've never
used it before, you
want to build something
called RemoteInput.
RemoteInput is
something you hang off
of an action that says,
by the way, if you
know how to send me text back,
please do it in this way.
And so you set up
a specific key,
so that when you get your intent
back from that action click,
you can extract out the
text that was entered.
Something I want to point your
attention to if you've already
been using RemoteInput,
you probably
have an activity there as the
pending intent on the input.
And it really, really needs
to be-- sot that action--
it needs to be a service
or broadcast receiver.
And here's why-- if you have
an action with an activity
intent on the lock screen, the
lock screen is going to say,
oh, the user wants
to go somewhere
when I click this thing.
And it's going to pop up that
authentication challenge--
it's going to pop up the
PIN pad, or the pattern,
or fingerprint,
or what have you.
But what you want to do
for a RemoteInput, where
you want the user to
be able to just type
straightaway on the
lock screen is make sure
it goes to a background
thing, like a broadcast
receiver or a service,
so that there's
no authentication required.
Now, if you're panicking and
going, whoa, whoa, hang on.
I don't want my
users to allow people
to send SMSs on their
behalf from the lock screen.
That is an end-user setting.
So if you go into Settings
as a user, you can say,
do I want to be able to type
into things on my lock screen
or not?
So that's covered
by system settings.
You don't have to
worry about it.
All you have to do is make
sure that that RemoteInput
is available for users who do
want to opt into that feature,
to just type away from the
lock screen or anywhere else.
One last thing I just
wanted to point out--
when you set up that-- wow.
You know what?
I'm glad this is happening
here in this room,
as opposed to like yesterday
during the keynote.
I'm cool with that.
So when you've got your
broadcast receiver,
you just want to make sure you
use this method-- RemoteInput
Get Results from Intent.
That's the way that you
extract that text back out.
And all of this sample code
is just stolen mercilessly
from our developer docs.
So particularly if you
download DP3, the developer
preview for Android, all of this
stuff is going to be in there.
You don't have to
copy it down-- you
can sketch it now
if you want-- you'll
be able to pull this
directly into your app
and get RemoteInput running.
Another thing that
I wanted to mention
is, after you get a
reply-- so here's the flow.
You post a notification,
the user touches
Reply, it types directly in
it, you get the intent back,
extract the text--
great, this is
what the user wanted to send
as a comment, or an SMS,
or whatever.
What do you do now?
So, previously, when
people do direct reply,
our pattern was that
you just dismiss
the notification-- you assume
the user is done with it.
Not anymore.
We assume now that
in N, a user is
going to decide to dismiss
that notification whenever
they want.
This way they can post
one or two quick messages
in rapid succession without
losing that context.
So after you get a
RemoteInput direct reply,
leave the notification up.
And more than that, you
actually want to re-notify
to signify, oh, yeah, we got it.
We got this.
It's been posted.
And we have this API
called Set RemoteInput
History that
basically all it does
is draw a little line underneath
your existing notification
content, whatever it was, and
then puts in any reply text
that you want.
So you can make a UI like
this where you say, oh, you've
left that comment.
And the user knows, OK, this
transaction has been completed,
I don't have to wonder
whether it's been posted.
I'm set.
So this works really
well for something
like leaving a comment on a
picture or something like that,
where you have the original
notification content,
and then you've got
replies that sit after it.
But that doesn't really
work all that well
for a chat, because chats
are back and forth--
you say something, they say
something, you say something,
they say something.
Set RemoteInput History
doesn't quite cover that case.
We've got something
even better for you,
but I'm going to hold that off
and let Alex talk about that,
because that's real fun.
In fact, why don't you
go ahead and get started.
The clicker's fidgety, maybe
it likes you better than me.
Let's try it.
ALEX HILLS: It
might, or maybe it
will advance seven times
for each time I click.
DAN SANDLER: That's right.
ALEX HILLS: Great.
All right, so Dan's
told you a little bit
about how N brings some pretty
big changes to the visual style
of notifications on the phone.
Well, I think that I'm
going to one up him
and say that Android Wear 2.0
is the biggest notification
redesign in the history
of Android Wear.
Which also happens to
be the only notification
redesign in the history
of Android Wear,
but I'm going to one-up Dan
anyway, so I'll take it.
Before I start, I do
want to mention briefly
that while this section applies
to all notifications on Wear,
it's mostly geared towards
bridge notifications coming
from a phone app.
If you want to learn some
other ways to approach this,
for notifications coming
from a local Wear app,
you can go to the Making Wear
Apps More Standalone talk
at 2:00 PM, or viewer.docs.
It doesn't like me.
Here we go.
So the very first
impression that a user
gets of your app's
notification is the card itself
in the context stream.
Let's talk a little
bit of history.
In Android Wear 1.x,
cards were cool.
You could specify
different card heights,
add big background images
for visual context,
you could toss in or hide a
small icon or a content icon,
and get all sorts of different
fonts and treatments.
All these features
provided a lot
of visual richness and impact
to the cards, themselves.
That said, the richness
could sometimes
backfire, like when the
background image itself
was mostly obscured by the
card, itself, or diverse font
treatments made it hard for
a user to actually determine
what was most important for
a notification at a glance.
We thought about
this, about what
the purpose of a
notification card
is, about the importance of
high glanceability-- and changed
things around a little
bit in Wear 2.0.
Notification cards now
look a little different.
Visually, all the
same components
are there-- like with N, I
promise they're all there.
But we've made them a little
more consistent and more
information first.
We've switched from
our card-based design
to a dark, bold, material theme.
We now use color to start
telling the story-- the color
that your app sets
in the notification
now applies to the entire
notification surface,
immersing the user
in your content.
Explicit typography and
intentional treatment help
give the user focus for the most
important information first.
The color treatment
also serves to bring
a bit of visual consistency and
coherence to the notification,
because you set the
color from your app.
Notifications
coming from you look
like they're coming from
you, and notifications
coming from another
app look like they're
coming from another app.
The other part of
this material update
is a set of changes to the
layout of the card, itself.
Remember though, like I said
before, all the same content is
there-- you can look at this
right over there, and trust me,
I've got it listed out
and broken out for you.
It's just switched
around a little bit.
First off, we take a
one-size-fits-all approach
to the actual notification-
all notifications are the same
size, one screen.
No more different card heights.
Second, we've taken the large
icon in the background--
that nice, rich icon there--
and we've brought it front
and center of the notification.
It's no longer partially
obscured by the card,
or anything like that.
We've also brought, yes, we've
also brought the small icon
from the card itself to--
well, it's still actually
on the notification, but
we've brought it down
to the bottom right
of that large icon.
Finally, the content text
and title are centered.
We've made the font treatment
a little more consistent,
with an emphasis
on glanceability.
Now that you know what your
notification looks like,
I'm going to put it in the
context of the actual system.
A little bit more history-- in
Android Wear 1.x, the context
stream could be a bit
confusing to navigate.
The stream was, ostensibly, a
single, n-length vertical list
of your notifications.
However, each of
those n notifications
could also have an m length
vertical list of cards--
creating a sort of m by x
like big scrollable space,
you could just watch the
interaction on the screen,
and kind of realize.
You could page down the
stream one, two, three,
a couple more
times, and then page
to the right a couple times.
At that point,
remembering how to get
back to where you were-- going
from, say, row 5 column 1
to row 2 column 1--
became a mental exercise
in memory and pathfinding.
Which is not exactly
ideal when you
are trying to rapidly
triage your notifications
on your tiny little
wrist computer.
On the other hand, the context
stream in Android Wear 2.0
is pretty simple to navigate.
Like in 1.x, the
stream is ostensibly
a single n-length
list of notifications.
Unlike in 1.x, that's it--
simple, easy, no pathfinding.
Also, just a quick
note, we fixed
one of the things that bugged me
the most about the old stream,
where you could flick from
card, to card, to card.
But if you had say
seven, or eight, or nine,
or 10 notifications,
you actually
can only go one at once,
paginating through them.
Now we've made it
possible to vertically
fling through those
notifications from top
to bottom, bottom
to top, et cetera.
Again, sort of a big old point
there for rapid usability.
Now if you've been thinking
about the implications of what
I've been saying here,
you've realized that
a one-size-fits-all approach
might not actually fit all
of your content.
In fact, because smart
watches are very small,
it probably will not fit all
of your content, and some of it
will be clipped.
To solve this problem,
Android Wear 2.0
introduces expanded
notifications.
Now, in the news stream,
the entire notification
is a tap target.
Tapping that notification
launches the expanded
notification experience.
This is automatically rendered
with Wear 2.0's new material
guidelines, which
allows you to provide
a lightweight, app-like
experience to your users
with minimal effort.
All of the notification
content is arranged vertically
in a single screen surface,
with the content first, followed
by the primary
action at the end.
All the other actions that
you add to your notification,
are put in the
WearableActionDrawer component,
which is a new component
you can learn more about,
by going to the Android Wear
2.0 Material Design session
at 3:00 PM.
Now, what do you need to do
to enhance your notifications
with this new, rich experience?
Nothing.
You get it all for free.
This example here is one of
the simpler notifications
that you can build-- it has a
text, title, icons, an action.
Three of those
things are actually
necessary to even
build a notification
in the first place.
And you do this, and all of
that nice material richness
just comes along for the ride.
That said, if you want your
notifications to really pop--
to be information-rich and
visually impactful-- you may
need to take full advantage
of the notification styles
and templates.
As you can see here,
expanded notifications
can be both information-dense
and visually engaging.
You can use templates like
Big Text or Big Picture,
and you can add extra pages
to get even more information
into the notification itself.
I'm going to dive into
each of these in a second,
but you can see here
the level of richness
and visual diversity that
you can get in an expanded
notification.
The first example there was
a big text notification,
which you can see here, with
the text content rendered
in the stream, and on the
expanded notification surface.
However, that
notification also has
an action with the
RemoteInput that Dan
was talking-- that we have
had for a couple years--
and choices which are rendered
directly on the expanded
notification itself, which
allows users to take action
directly, or even respond
without having to talk
or type from the
notification surface.
The next example
was a notification
with two Big Picture
cards added to it,
whose images get put straight
on the expanded notification
surface, which creates a sort
of immersive photo-viewing
experience, just
from a notification.
Now, I'm about to show
you some code for all
of this, so just look closely
to remember what we're actually
going to be building.
This is most of the code.
Now, those two images are extra
pages in the notification,
and extra pages are
actually notifications
in their own right.
So we're going to create
a notification first.
Then we're going to set that
notification style to a Big
Picture style, and
then attach your image
to the style with a simple
chain method call on it.
To make the second big
picture, copy/paste
works just as well in
code as it does in slides,
so just do that.
And then, to actually
add those pages,
we're going to need to
create a wearable extender,
and add those two
notifications as pages to it.
Finally, we're going to build
the notification, itself,
by creating a builder,
setting the title, text,
and icons, and
finally, extending
the notification with
the wearable extender
that we built earlier.
The rest is as simple as calling
notificationManager Notify,
and you'll end up with an
expanded notification, just
like that, with this rich
photo-viewing experience.
Now, I do also want to
mention that extra pages can
be heterogeneous, and you
can mix and match them
to get exactly what you want.
This lets you make
rich notifications--
like this one--
for a user's ticket
to see "Space Fights VII."
Notification has
three extra pages
containing a QR ticket, movie
details, and the plot synopsis.
As you can see here,
all of those pages
are stacked vertically
in the order
that you add them,
which essentially allows
you to use extra pages
as building blocks
to construct the expanded
notification exactly
as you want.
This makes it easy to create
an engaging and useful wear
experience without actually
having to make an app.
Finally, I want
to talk about one
of the keynotes of Wear 2.0's
communications improvements--
MessagingStyle.
MessagingStyle is an entirely
new notification style,
introduced with
Android Wear 2.0,
which gives users a full
back-and-forth chat experience
right within the notification.
When a user taps into the
expanded notification itself,
they're going to have
access to the full context
of their conversation,
letting them get, say,
right back to the work
chat from the day before,
or the conversation with their
friends about how "Space Fight
VII" was really awesome, way
better than the prequels,
and maybe even lived
up to the originals.
You'll also notice that
the chat history includes
sender names there, meaning that
group conversations work well,
too.
That said, MessagingStyle is
not just about formatting.
You could theoretically
do all of this yourself,
with a Big Text.
And actually, most of you who
have messaging apps already
are, and just adding
it as an extra page
with Wearable Extender.
The real key to
MessagingStyle is actually
how MessagingStyle
and RepoteInput
work in concert to give
the user this experience.
Unlike the other
uses of RemoteInput,
the user replying won't
actually drop them out
of the expanded notification.
Instead, their response
is going to show
up immediately, in line, on the
notification surface itself.
This means that users are going
to see their messages instantly
in front of them, before
a round-trip to the phone
and your app has completed.
This makes the user
experience very responsive,
and fast, and feels
just very good all out.
If your app reposts the
notification with new content,
it will also update
in place, meaning
that responses and
replies by other users
also show up in this surface,
without the user having
to, say, go out and back
in, or retap a notification
or anything.
It's all right there, giving
that full back-and-forth chat
experience in the notification.
Now, you're all
savvy developers,
and have probably noticed
that these RemoteInput
choices have been really good--
way better than they should be.
You also may actually
have mentally linked
that to David's talk in
the keynote, if you're
especially savvy.
But the summary is
that, in the future,
we are going to be
bringing the Smart Reply
feature from Inbox and Allo to
MessagingStyle notifications
on Wear.
Meaning that you,
as a developer,
can optionally give
your users dynamically
generated, quality,
contextual responses
to pick from, all for free.
[WHISTLE]
Good, yeah, it's very cool.
Let's be clear.
Now I'm going to talk
about a little bit of code.
To actually use
MessagingStyle, and to get
it to work end-to-end,
you're going
to need to create a reply
action with a RemoteInput.
While technically
not necessary, as I
mentioned before, the real
goodness of MessagingStyle
comes from how
the MessagingStyle
and RemoteInput work together.
Just one on their own
just only gives you
half of the experience.
Now this slide is actually
completely shamelessly
copied from Dan's
slide, which is,
in turn, shamelessly copied from
our developer documentation,
including the Android
version call-outs.
So all I'm going to
say now is that you
need to do this, and move on.
Creating the MessagingStyle
itself is actually very simple.
You simply need to create a
new instance of MessagingStyle,
with the reply name
that's going to show up
when the user replies in place.
And then add all of the previous
messages from the conversation
to the style by
calling add message,
with the text, time, and sender.
Finally, you just need to
build the notification itself.
Build it as normal, set the
style to MessagingStyle,
and add the action that
I completely glossed
over, and call Notify.
That's really, actually,
all there is to it.
If you notice, and
were paying attention,
that's a little
bit easier, even,
than just adding two
pictures to a notification
in the first place.
Now, with that code we've just
gone through on your phone app,
you are able to give your users
a full back-and-forth chat
experience on Android Wear.
That's it-- nothing else.
Now, to go back to
about 10-ish minutes
ago, when Dan mentioned that
there was a better way of doing
chat notifications on the phone
than using set RemoteInput
history, I have some good news.
We learned from the path that
RemoteInput and notification
groups took, and
this time, we're
going to be bringing a
Wear feature to the phone
immediately, instead of
waiting a year or two for it
to show up.
MessagingStyle on the phone
works just like on Wear,
using RemoteInput for direct
replies, as you can see here.
Additionally, if the user does
still want that full, great app
experience that you've built--
and I'm sure they will--
they just have to tap the
notification to deep link
into your app, just like before.
Now, a quick note here is
that we've put a lot of effort
into making MessagingStyle
work on Android 2.0 devices,
no matter what version of
Android they are paired to.
This means that users
running phones with an OS
as early as Jelly Bean still
get MessagingStyle goodness
on Android Wear.
All you have to do is these
three things in your phone app.
First, you have to use
NotificationCompat.Builder, as
opposed to NotificationBuilder.
Second, you have to
use NotificationCompat
MessagingStyle, instead of
Notification MessagingStyle--
to be fair, these are both
things that you're probably
already doing,
because compatibility
is pretty important here.
And then third-- and you're
probably already doing this,
if you're a messaging app, which
I mentioned before-- you need
to add the user's chat
history as an extra page
with wearableExtender,
to continue
to support Android Wear 1.x.
If you've done
these things, you're
going to end up
with the following,
as shown by these handy
tiny little charts.
First, on Android Wear 2.0,
regardless of what version
the phone is
running, you're going
to get MessagingStyle,
everything that I showed you,
full chat experience,
right in the notification.
On Wear 1.x, pairs
to any phone, you're
going to get the
standard notification
card in the stream, and because
you added that extra page,
it's going to show
up and your users
are still going to get
their chat history.
Because MessagingStyle
is a bespoke experience
on Android Wear 2.0,
we don't actually
show those extra pages.
Finally, on the phone,
if your user's running N,
they're going to get
MessagingStyle notification.
And if they're not,
NotificationCompat
ensures that they still get
the standard notification
experience.
All these things
summed up together
mean that if you use
MessagingStyle and these two
other things that I said, you
get the best of all worlds,
no matter what device is
paired, no matter what version
those devices are running.
So what actual steps
do you, a developer,
need to take to work
with the changes
that we've made in
Android Wear 2.0?
First, you need to make
sure that the notification
in the stream itself is rapidly
glanceable-- which basically
means, focus on the text.
Second, to get all of this
expanded notification goodness,
and really take full
advantage of it,
use extra content pages
with wearableExtender
to really structure
those building blocks,
and build the experience
out for your users.
Third-- and this is also
pretty important-- is
that notifications, as
you noticed, are dark now.
That means that color
spannables and display
intents for your notifications
are actually maybe not going
to work as well
as you would like,
because you need to support
dark backgrounds on 2.0,
and light backgrounds on 1.x.
Kind of hard to find
colors that work on both.
That said, quick
call-out here, if you
have a standalone app,
a Wear app at all,
all you have to do to
make this work is just
check the API level at
runtime, or use a resource
qualifier to adjust your
colors as necessary.
You can still use
them as normal.
Finally, the last bit--
if you're a messaging app,
make sure that you use
NotificiationCompat
and MessagingStyle
to give your users
an awesome Wear
experience, without having
to write the Wear app.
If any of this stuff interests
you, and it probably should,
just go to g.co/wearpreview,
and you can get the preview SDK,
device images, and more
information about the new APIs
that we're going
to be launching.
DAN SANDLER: All
right, fantastic.
Thank you, Alex.
Is everybody still awake?
Do we need to stand up, shake
a leg, drink coffee, anything?
We've got a few
more things that I
want to cover here--
let's switch places
so I can poke the computer--
a few more things we
want to talk about.
And then if we
have time, I'd love
to open it up for questions.
Let's get through it.
First, I want to draw
your attention-- OK, let's
make sure the keyboard works.
So this guy here-- he
had a lot less hair--
answered the question at Google
I/O 2012, when they first
introduced rich notifications
with Jelly Bean,
and at the same time,
introduced the ability for users
to block notifications that
they found inappropriate,
or spammy, or what have you.
And somebody got up at the mic
and said, excuse me, as an app,
can I find out when the user
has blocked my notifications?
And this guy got up
there and said, no.
[LAUGHS]
So actually, this is
pretty easy to do.
The initial implementation,
actually you couldn't do it.
But when App Ops
came along, which
you may know is the foundation
of our permissions system,
we moved notification
blocking over to App Ops,
because, hey, it's a
new system facility
for exactly this sort of thing.
And it turns out that,
because of some performance
optimizations in App Ops, you
can, from any app, at runtime,
do some funky introspection
and just check
to see whether an
operation is allowed
before even invoking it.
It makes it much faster to do
certain kinds of operations.
So yeah, you can find out
whether your notifications
have been blocked by
reflecting in Java.
So, at the time we
were really worried
that if apps knew when their
notifications were being
blocked, the world would end.
It's 2016, four years later,
the world has not ended.
So we said fine, you know what?
Let's just make a
real API for this,
because we think
there are actually
some legitimate uses of it.
So I'll get to that in a second.
You can say, NotificationMana
ger.areNotificationsEnabled.
Real easy-- like,
has the user blocked
my notifications or not?
And you don't have to
do those ugly hacks,
and you don't have to go
online and look that stuff up.
And the reason we
introduced this,
in addition to wanting to
reduce the number of places
that people had to
resort to those hacks,
is that you can actually
create a better experience.
Here's the situation-- a
user feels like they're not
getting notifications
from your app,
and they don't understand why.
So they go into the app,
they go into Settings,
they see all the
boxes are ticked,
notifications are turned on.
I don't know what's wrong.
One star.
So now, what you can do in
your app, in your settings--
this is a mock-up, that I used
Gmail as a guinea pig here,
but obviously you can do
this in your own app--
if a user goes in to modify
notification settings,
your app could go and say,
well, hang on a second,
you blocked notifications
at the system level.
There's nothing we can do until
you go in and unblock that.
So you can alert users
to those conflicts,
and I think that's a
great user experience.
If you do use this in
some sort of abusive way,
if you use this API to
create some kind of arms race
with the user-- oh, you
blocked my notifications,
I'm going to use a top-level
system alert window,
or whatever-- I will
come and find you.
So don't do it.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's see, other
stuff you want to know
about-- if you use Builder--
and if you're not using Builder,
we have to have another
dot conversation,
because Set Latest Event
Info doesn't work anymore.
If you're using Builder,
we've changed a little bit
how the memory works.
It used to, whenever
you called Build,
it would construct
a new notification
object that was a
snapshot of its state
and hand that off to you.
Now it actually retains that
object internally, and just
gives you a pointer.
That big reason for this is
that notifications are huge.
They didn't used to
be, but now people
adding wearable extenders,
and car extenders,
and lots of big
bitmaps and things
like that-- they're
big objects, and we
didn't want you to have to
suffer that in your memory
partition every time
you constructed up
a new notification.
So when you're
using Builder, it is
holding onto that prototypical
embryonic notification,
and when you call Build, you
just get a pointer to it.
If you're not expecting
that kind of behavior,
the way things work in N
is going to be possibly
a little confusing.
But this actually will
make memory better for you.
It makes memory better
on the system overall.
This is also important when
you are posting updates
to notifications.
We see a lot of
people in the field
caching their
notification object,
and then using either
poking directly
into the slots on that POJO
or using RemoteViews methods
to try to update progress
bars and things like that
in the notification.
You can't do that anymore.
I mean, you can,
it's not really going
to work because--
well, I'll get to what
happens to those
RemoteViews in a second.
What you want to do, if
you are posting updates
to your notification and you
want to keep some memory around
as long as your app is still
live, is hold onto the Builder.
The Builder will hold
onto the notification.
It'll will be nice and fast to
just go and talk to the Builder
and make your changes
there, and call Build again.
This is a good
bully pulpit for me
to remind you about
features we've
introduced over the
last couple of years,
that you may not be using yet.
Since L notifications
have been available
on the lock screen on
all L Android devices,
but users have
different tolerances
for what kind of content is
appropriate on the lock screen.
The lock screen is kind
of a public place--
if they've got PIN
password fingerprint
security, potentially anybody
can pick your phone up
off a cab seat, and
take a look at it.
So if a user has
opted into what we
call "hide sensitive
content" notifications
on the lock screen, your
notification is just really
not going to say
anything interesting,
unless you specifically say,
oh, here's a public version.
Here's a version that's
safe for the phone that's
found in the backseat
of a cab, or even just
laying face-up on your
desk when somebody else is
sitting in the same room.
So go ahead and use
setPublicVersion
to supply a version of
that notification that's
OK for users who are
security conscious.
Or if it's something like
a weather widget, or media
playback, when you want it to
be available at all times-- say,
you know what?
I'm just going to set the
visibility of this notification
to public, and then it's
appropriate anywhere,
and you don't have to make
a separate version for it.
Something else I
wanted to mention
is the way the Do
Not Disturb works.
So hopefully, you've had
a chance to play around
with the Do No Disturb
that we made really, really
good in Marshmallow.
The way that it knows what
things are phone calls
or alarms, to allow
the user to put
the phone into alarms-only
mode and get those alarms,
or into priority
mode and get phone
calls from important people,
is with your metadata
in the Builder.
And the two big ones are
setCategory and addPerson.
SetCategory allows
you to say, this
is an alarm-- I know I'm
not the built-in alarm clock
app, or the OEM's
built-in alarm clock app,
but I've got this cool
app called Timely,
and it's got an
alarm, and it should
be treated as alarms
when the user says,
go into alarms-only mode.
Use setCategory to
mark it that way.
Similarly, addPerson
is the way that users
are allowed to opt
certain human beings in
to be able to break through
their priority settings.
And so you say,
addPerson-- and we
accept anything that we could
use to look that person up
in the system contacts database.
So you can throw--
yeah, if you've
got a content URI
for that person
in the contacts
database, awesome.
We'll just look it straight up.
But you can also just supply
an email address, or a phone
number.
And we'll go ahead and look
that up and in contacts DB.
Particularly if your
app doesn't really
want to interact with the
Android contacts database,
but it is
phone-number-based, you
can give us the phone
number in the notification,
we'll look it up.
If the user has
starred that contact,
that notification can bust
through priority mode.
Which is a great
feature for users
that want to tune
out of most things,
but there are some
people that should
be able to get a hold
of them at any time.
I just want to remind you
that MediaStyle exists--
that was the new template that
we introduced last time around.
If you are building a
music player, or anything
that kind is like a music
player-- such as background
control of some sort
remote playback thing,
or video player, what
have you-- use MediaStyle,
and we'll take care of all
the details of making it look
good on every platform version.
And I mentioned earlier, there
was the Decorating Custom View
Style-- if you feel like
you really need a custom
RemoteViews, there's a decorated
MediaStyle style-- I forget
what it's called-- look in
the API docs, I have to,
as well-- to be able to get the
system annotation of the app
name, and so forth, and the
actions along with the media.
The other thing that I wanted
to mention specifically
about MediaStyle is
that if you were worried
about using setColor-- which is
the notification accent color
feature-- if you were worried
about using that because it
made your media playback
notification look garish,
it doesn't do that anymore.
So in N, we are only
using that color
to tint some of the
playback controls.
So it should be a
little bit safer
to take your media
player's brand colors--
whether it's some livid green,
or orange, or what have you--
and set that as the
color on your MediaStyle,
and it should look
really good on N.
This is where we have a very,
very brief moment of silence
for APIs that are no longer
with us-- specifically
all of the direct access to
RemoteViews on notification.
They're not going to work,
because we're not even
creating them.
Time was when you created
a notification even
with the Builder
and called Build,
we would generate a whole
RemoteViews that looked exactly
like that notification is going
to appear on the other side,
and then we would stuff that
thing into a parcelable,
and push it all through
binder to the system server,
push all the system
you want-- yeah,
we just don't do that anymore.
The RemoteViews is not there.
If you have a custom
RemoteViews and you set it,
those slots will be there.
But if you use the Builder
methods, these APIs--
contentView, bigContentView,
headsUpContentView
are not there.
So you use Builder.setContent.
And actually, we
renamed that method
to setCustomContentView
to make it better match
the other stuff that's been
developed in the meantime.
All right, so this is
for like two of you
in the room who are using
NotificationListenerService--
one of them is you, because
that's how Wear works-- if you
have a
NotificationListenerService,
one of the things that we
noticed after releasing
this API, 86 years
ago, is that when
we bind them from system
UI, or binding them
from the Notification
Manager, we've
been binding for the
lifetime of the system,
because we thought of them as
an extension of the system UI.
They are really expensive.
So now, if you have
a listener that
only needs to listen
occasionally-- like we're only
listening when
you're in the car,
or we're only listening
when you're on a run,
or only listening when you're
using this particular app
or experience-- you
can say, requestUnbind.
Like, the user has approved
me as a notification listener,
but I don't need to
be bound right now.
I'll let you know when
it's important to bind me
again, and start sending
me notifications.
So this can really improve
performance of the device,
it can improve memory pressure.
I think that's all the sundries.
There's lots and lots
of resources online.
Obviously DP3 is out--
you should go get
that APK, go get that package.
We also have sample
code, we've updated
them to show off
groups and summaries,
our standard active
notification sample, and GitHub.
And then the Messaging
Service update
demos RemoteInput-- I don't know
if it demos MessagingStyle yet,
I think that's still
damp with how new it is.
So it's not in Messaging
Service yet, but it will be.
ALEX HILLS: The Wear
docs do call that out.
DAN SANDLER: The
Wear docs mission?
OK.
So, as developers, what do?
Test your existing
notifications on N, definitely.
If you have lots
of notifications
that you're already posting,
and you're not grouping them,
please, please group them.
Nobody likes to turn on
a phone in the morning
and get 36 notifications
of all the stuff that
happened while you were asleep.
Add direct reply where
it's appropriate, where
you can accept reply text.
And then if you're using
custom notifications,
do you look at that
DecoratedCustomViewStyle,
so users will get the benefit
of the app attribution,
and the expand affordance.
And now, there's Wear stuff.
ALEX HILLS: Back to Wear just
a little bit-- we're actually
holding a lot of sessions.
So this is a list, if you
want to come see more,
starting with the big one--
What's New in Android Wear
2.0-- and then a
couple of the others
that I actually mentioned
during my portion of the talk.
Also, as you know, if
you've missed anything,
all of these talks are going
to be available on YouTube.
DAN SANDLER: Kind of
shockingly quickly.
ALEX HILLS: Yeah, and finally,
the Android Wear sandbox,
you can go to it
for more questions
and live demos-- it is the
green square on this map.
It also is just through this
wall, and a little bit further.
Though, probably go around
instead of actually through.
DAN SANDLER: So we have
time maybe for one or two
live questions, if you want
to get up on the mic and ask.
Otherwise, we're
going to be outside.
And also, we've enabled
the new Google Spaces
app for this talk--
many of the talks today
have Spaces
associated with them,
or you can go and communicate
with the people in this room,
and everybody else
that came to IO
to talk about this
topic, post your examples
of your favorite
notifications and least
favorite notifications.
But we've got a couple
minutes, let's go ahead
and take some questions
from the room.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: On the Wear
notifications, the new style,
you said you can
set the background
color of those cards?
ALEX HILLS: Correct,
using the setColor API,
which is actually what
Dan talked about--
with regards to
MediaStyle specifically--
calling setColor for
your notification
will tint things on
big Android, and will
also on the littlest
of Androids,
set the background color
for all of those cards.
AUDIENCE: Does it set it
directly, or just tint it?
ALEX HILLS: We use a
darkened version of it.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
AUDIENCE: For the
list groups, is there
a limit for how big
that group could be?
DAN SANDLER: So there's
a practical limit
that no package can post
more than 50 notifications.
You shouldn't really be
posting that many at all,
but you can imagine a situation
where you've got five accounts,
and you want to have
10 messages-- that
seems reasonable.
I don't remember if we actually
ended up creating a limit,
but you'll notice
that you'll start
to see system performance
suffer if you're posting all 50
into that group
at the same time.
Not least, because
it's not useful--
the user is not going to want
to triage that much stuff.
Our recommendation
is on the order
of five, maybe as many as 10.
Only your observation
of user behavior
will tell you what is actually
going to be useful to people.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAN SANDLER: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I have
a music streaming
app that supports Chromecast.
And we actually had to drop
the MediaStyle notification
to match the requirements of the
Chromecast user best practices.
Is there any plans
to add a Chromecast
icon, or a disconnect
button to that media stuff?
DAN SANDLER: So I don't
know what the underlap is
between those two APIs.
So we should talk
after, and that
sounds like the
kind of thing that
would be good-- there's a bug
tracker specifically dedicated
to Android N previews.
That's a good place to
raise that kind of issue,
because we are triaging those
bugs pretty aggressively,
and taking action on them.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
DAN SANDLER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When does
the app get to know
notifications are disabled?
Is there any listener,
or only when it resumes?
DAN SANDLER: No,
there's no broadcast.
So you can't find
out-- what we really
don't want you to do is to try
to min/max the user's behavior,
and try to respond in real
time to when the user becomes
so enraged that they
block notifications.
It's expressly created so
that you can do things like I
showed in the screenshot.
When the user has problems,
you can say, well,
here's one of the
reasons that you
might be having those problems.
So there's no listener.
AUDIENCE: But the
app will detect when
it is in the foreground, right?
DAN SANDLER: Yeah, I mean, you
can check at any time, yeah.
AUDIENCE: What [INAUDIBLE]
Wear in the market?
Are all Android Wear
accounts upgradeable 2.0?
If yes, when?
DAN SANDLER: It's a Wear
2.0 availability question.
ALEX HILLS: All
right, so Wear 2.0
is going to be available
later this fall.
To be fair, also, the developer
preview is available right now
on the site that I linked--
g.code/wearpreview.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank
you very much.
DAN SANDLER: Thank you.
All right, I think that's it.
Thank you so much.
We'll see you on Spaces, and
thank you for showing up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]